Speaker 1: We have now learned that indeed failed.
Former President Donald Trump had documents with
nuclear secrets on them at his house at Mar
a Lago. And the immediate question becomes,
what the hell was he planning to do with those?
Was he planning to sell them? Did he sell them?
And of course, all sorts of speculation running
rampant. So let's go back and start at the top.
It was speculated that there might have been
documents relating to nuclear capabilities
at Donald Trump's Mar a Lago, part of the search
warrant served by the FBI at his home. We now have
gotten confirmation of that from The Washington
Post's Devlin Barrett and Carol Leonnig,
a document describing a foreign governments
military defenses, including nuclear capabilities,
was found by FBI agents who searched former
President Donald Trump's Mar a Lago residence
and private club last month, according to people
familiar with the matter, underscoring concerns
among U.S. intelligence officials about classified
materials stashed in the Florida property,
some of the seized documents detailed top
secret U.S. operations so closely guarded
that many senior national security officials are
kept in the dark about them. Only the president,
some members of his cabinet or a near cabinet
level official could authorize other government
officials to know details of these special access
programs. Documents about such highly classified
operations require special clearances on a need to
know basis, not just a top secret, top, top secret
clearance. Some special access programs can
have as few as a couple dozen government
personnel authorized to know about the operations
existence. Records that deal with such programs
are kept under lock and key, almost always in a
secure compartmented information facility with a
designated control officer to keep careful tabs on
their location. These documents sometimes require
the constant surveillance of the documents
to know exactly where they are at all times.
And Trump had them at his house. Trump had them at
his house. This is getting worse every single day.
Now, the timing of this release, I believe, and
many do as well, I'm not unique in this belief.
I didn't come up with this, that the timing is
related to the appointment of a special master
to oversee the documents that even Trump's
own former attorney general, William Barr,
thinks is inappropriate and is a decision that
will ultimately be reversed. And I do believe the
timing is in order to counteract that and to sort
of say, all right, well, you figure out a way to
delay things. But more and more information
is going to come out. Now, why would Trump,
who has a lot of debt, relied on a lot of foreign
money to become president? Why would Trump keep
documents about the nuclear capabilities of
other countries at his house? Do you think
Trump is aware that many adversaries of the
United States would be willing to pay for those
documents? Is Trump aware that many adversaries
of the United States would love to try to steal
certain documents? Do we still believe that there
is a perfectly innocent explanation for this?
I don't. I don't. And I'm starting to think maybe
it's not true that Trump wanted these documents so
that he could write his memoirs or said that
they could be in his presidential library,
which by all accounts, he doesn't even care
about. Now, here is Trump's lawyer, one of
Trump's lawyers, Olena Haber, just yesterday
mocking the idea that the stolen documents
included nuclear secrets. This was yesterday.
Speaker 4: I saw this meme that was very funny
on Instagram, I believe it was. And it said it's
amazing. At first it was the codes to the nuclear
weapons. Now it's invisible classified documents.
Speaker 1: So she's mocking the idea
that there were nuclear related documents
there. And yet there are and yet there are.
You really have to wonder, what else has Trump
done over the last four or five, six years
that we haven't even learned about yet? And as
I've said before, I believed it would take years
to learn the full scope of what he did. And it's
taking years. It's taking years. And this is all
you know, there's a couple different possibilities
here, as I said, about the timing. One possibility
is this is the intel community fighting back or
signaling back about the special master decision,
saying, you know, you can put in place a special
master, but we can keep releasing more and more
every day about the damaging reality of what
Donald Trump did. The other possibility here is
that the special master, obviously the intent
of that by Trump is to just slow down what's
going on, maybe particularly in the context of the
midterms. And the intel community here is saying
we can accelerate the release of this information.
Now, I can't believe I'm actually saying this,
but this is potentially treasonous, what Donald
Trump has done. If you look at a couple of
different statutes, 18 U.S. Code subsection 794 is
called gathering or delivering defense information
to aid foreign government. Okay. We're talking
about crimes there. And check Google the statute
and read it for yourself. It's quite lengthy.
Another possibility, 18 U.S. Code 793 gathering,
transmitting or losing defense information. Also
a crime. This is extraordinarily serious. And
of course, listen at every step. We knew it was
serious when we learned about the investigations.
We knew it was serious when the FBI decided to do
the raid. We knew it was serious when Trump and
his cronies started throwing absurd, conflicting
explanations at the wall to see what sticks. We
knew it was very serious. And now that this has
been found, we know it is even more serious. And
unfortunately for Trump, his lawyers are rapidly
deteriorating. When confronted about these issues.